it's going to be up to the big
left-hander sean manaya tonight as he
takes the field
he's sporting the all-white home
uniforms so now two umpires are over
there what they're going to talk to him
about it looks like is the color of the
glove you mean the same glove that he's
used for every start the entire
season
and they're probably going to tell him
he's got to use a different glove this
is just come on this is ridiculous it's
laughable he has not thrown a single
pitch it's the glove he uses
rule 3.07 pitchers glove the pitcher's
glove may not exclusive exclusive or
piping be white gray nor in the judgment
of an umpire distracting in any manner
and the first pitch is grounded up the
middle harrison dives his throw to first
and what a play by josh harrison
sensational play by harrison i don't
know how he got him
had the game-winning rbi yesterday 66
ribbies
and he singles to right field
that one is ripped into left field to
base hit
he struck him out big strikeout for
mania the yankee ace garrett cole yeah
garrett cole on the bound tonight for
the yankees and you can see his numbers
are all good 12 wins and six losses
a little flip job to center it's gonna
fall in front of judge for a base hit
check swing 100 miles an hour did he go
yes he did as olson down on strikes
and that hit him he's going to limp a
little bit toward first he's a big guy
as you can see
[Applause]
swing gonna miss right past him 94.
strike three call for back-to-back
strikeouts from manana
[Applause]
rounded to third backhanded by urshela
fires across the diamond to get chapman
you know if anybody can appreciate that
play with the guy who hit it that's the
sort of play that chapman has made over
the years
that earns him gold and platinum gloves
[Applause]
up the middle
yeah nice play by the shortstop but he
throws it low and cannons aboard
rounded to velasquez this one's an easy
toss to rizzo one two two judge who had
a base hit to right field in the first
and he could not hold up kind of a half
swing strikeout number four for sean
manaya
that's a shot to left and that's a base
hit marty's aboard with two outs
obtain that going
and they said he went around but the
ball is loose
olson is gonna head down to first now
marty is gonna try for third and marte
is gonna make it to third
so if the ball hits you yes yeah and
that's what they're calling so the ball
once the ball hits olson
it's a dead ball and he's swung at it so
it's a strikeout yes as well as
giancarlo stanton his last eight games
ken five home runs 333 batting average
ops way up there 13.82
there it goes don't move see ya
oh what a shot
a home run for stanton that landed
somewhere near san francisco it's
one-nothing inks
[Applause]
472 feet
oh my goodness that should count for two
home runs and michael it's not that he
hits home runs it's just
it's an effortless swing luke voight is
the hitter
that one is ripped deep to center field
and that ball is gone
a home run for voight
and the yankees lead two nothing
well there's been a display of power in
this inning
gets the leg down
boom
pitch in the middle of the plate adios
swing and a miss at 100 miles an hour
lowry down on strikes so the red sox the
number two
wild card team
judge going back and it's over his head
plays it gets it back in quickly but
harrison's gonna have a double
not close
the o2
strike three fastball right down the
middle
strike three
murphy down looking three strikeouts for
cole in the inning
that one is wrapped in the left center
field it's a base hit cutting over his
marte
and stopping it first the big turn is
kyle higashioga that's a nice play by
martay
grounded through for base hit
back back-to-back singles to open up the
fifth inning and that brings up judge
judges one for two singled in the first
and struck out in the third
that one is driven to center field and
deep going back is martay on the track
at the wall leaks see ya a three-run
home run for judge and the yankees lead
five-nothing
well we talked about
the yankee power of late
it looked like a high change up
and judge knew what to do with it
base hit past lemay
ernest andrews with a lead off single
and a fly ball to center field and the
first pitch is a base hit right center
field elvis anders is gonna round second
he's gonna head for third he'll make it
standing up and the a's have first and
third nobody out
another 3-2 pitch here it is
the o2
swing and a miss got a big strikeout for
garrett cole
all right so here is harrison dangerous
he's one for two aces loaded two outs
blind drive and caught by hershela he
took a two-run single away from josh
harrison
and cole deals
swing and i missed the slider stay up a
little later tonight
yeah he went did he go yes he did so
canada down on strikes strikeout number
199 for cole this year
the 1-2 caught on it miss struck him out
swinging what a way to finish
garrett cole strikes out the side he has
nine strikeouts through six and he has
200 strikeouts for the year
five nothing yankees in the seventh the
lefties pitch and that is down and away
ball four so the a's do have a base run
martay hits it hard and that's the base
hit in the left field arte's got two
more hits tonight
matt olson the hitter another
opportunity for the a's to get back in
it
when chopped into left field and that's
the base hit pinder's gonna come around
and score the throws wide it goes all
the way to the backstop marty's gonna
try and score he's gonna make it just
like that it's five to two
grounded this should be two there's one
and there's two
green gets out of trouble uh here's
heggy
high fly ball deep right center field
pinder on the run looking up see ya a
home run for higashiyoka and it is 7-2
yankees
power the other way
judge with a three-run home run in the
fifth also singled in the first so he's
two for four
and that one is rip to left field to
base hit lemayo rounds third he's coming
home here's the throw
cut off it's an rbi single for judge
and the yankees lead eight to two
lucas lipke is entrusted to get the
final
three outs of this game
eight two yankees the pitch
strike three ball game over the yankees
have won 13 in a row all they do is win
win win no matter what the yankees
refuse to lose
[Applause]